So, it's my pleasure to get to introduce
Bogdan
Arsinte Asco.
Uh, who is lead software architect at
Microsoft, uh, based out of New York
City now coming up.
And uh
Bogdan will be speaking about graph
systems for data in motion. I could give
I I highlighted sections out of this,
but I don't think I would do justice.
But, this is, uh, one of the talks I
really anticipated. So, I give you some
background though. Uh, Bogdan is a real
real-time systems architect at
Microsoft. He's led teams that build and
operated, uh, large-scale graphs, uh,
going back to 20
10, uh, working on Pregel, uh,
high-performance compute for, uh, Google
knowledge graph.
And, uh, also worked on scale-out for
operational systems at LinkedIn, uh,
graph analytics at Microsoft Fabric.
And, earlier he had designed and
implemented graph algorithms,
uh, to get the
20 km of wire into 4 square cm for
silicon design.
So, knows a thing or two about, uh,
working with graphs at scale, I would
say. Please join us in welcoming Bogdan.
>> Thank you. Is this thing on? Can you
hear me?
>> Yes.
>> Okay.
So uh
this is a continuation of a talk that
I've done
last year.
Where should I stay?
To avoid this. Here?
All right.
Um, where, you know, the the point being
that we collect a lot of data and, uh,
it's in lake, it's in, uh, warehouses.
We have to make sense of it. And, uh,
throughout the, uh, experience that I
collected is how do you do this without,
uh, requiring graphs of hundreds of
petabytes of, uh, of data because that's
nobody's going to want to pay for that.
Um although if you know somebody that
wants to pay for it, let them talk to me
because I work for Microsoft and we
would like those kind of clients.
Um data in motion. So, I have a very
broad systemic view of what data in
motion is. You know, it's experimental
or personal data, so there's a little
bit of data on top of um
you know, the warehouse that you see
there.
Uh
multiple data domains, how do you
control access to those domains, how do
you build graphs to uh to do that, and
you know, real-time graphs where data
keeps on coming, there's an infinite uh
amount of data that uh that keeps on
arriving.
So,
I'll split the presentation into cases.
I'll try to convince you that silos are
bad, and then I'll try to convince you
that silos are good.
Um and for the case against silos, you
know, I'm going to talk about how do we
overlay the data, how do we grow the
graphs, how do we build graphs that are
viable.
How do we do experimentation
in production with graphs?
And in the second part of the
presentation, I'll talk about domains
and how do you do uh role-related access
to graphs, and how do you partition the
graph such that only the right people
have access to the right kind of graphs
for economic reasons, for
you know, for cost reasons.
And then uh in the end, you know, what
do we do with streaming data? What do we
do with uh with data that keeps on
coming? So, it's not really about
streaming. So, when I'm talking about
real-time data or data in motion, I'm
talking about your data empire is
changing all the time because there are
no no sources of truth. There are new
insights that you want to gather. You
want to update the models that you have
over the data.
So, what's in a graph? Um I'll start
talking GQL because uh it's a you know,
good thing to to change the paradigm and
use the the new standard um um
terminology. Uh GQL talks about graph
type instead of talking about schema.
And a graph has a set of types of nodes
and a set of types of edges, and all
those create a graph type.
The way you bring the graph in from your
sources of truth is you create a graph
definition, which is what we called
modeling or transformation before.
Um and that graph definition tells how
do we index the data? How do we get the
data from the
source into the graph indices?
In everything that I talk and everything
that I've done in the last
13 years, there's never been a database.
There's never been a durable storage for
the graph because there was never a need
for it. And your CIO doesn't want to pay
for another database, and your engineers
don't want to maintain another ETL. So,
everything that I'm going to talk about
is an index. The data stays in the
source of truth. I have a model,
and I want to create the right model for
the right vicinity of the data in in the
graph.
So, you know, you have a graph type, you
have a graph definition, and you have
the graph the graph data, nodes and
edges.
A simple example, you know, and and this
is, you know, for all of you that have
tried um a, you know, the Neo4j
community edition,
you know, you have a table of
nodes and a table of edges.
You know, and in my table of edges, you
know, the second
the second table of nodes is implied. It
just has a string, and you're going to
index on that.
So, these are the two types, you know,
there's one node type, one edge type. My
node type says I have a person ID. It
has four properties, first name, last
name, gender, birthday. And you have a
table of edges that has the person ID,
and at the other end of the edge you
have the the languages that they speak.
That's my schema. That's my graph type.
This is the graph definition. The The
data is coming from somewhere in your
estate, from a table.
And you take that table and you map it
into a
um uh um
node table and you map it into an edge
table and you do the same thing for all
the data sets that that you want to to
bring in. You have a hundred data sets
that you want to bring in, you take this
thing and you replicate it a hundred
times with different definitions and
different wiring and that's all of it.
Why do I think that that is important to
talk about? Um and we'll get to it a
little bit later.
Now, everything that I talk about graph
definition is a view.
So, I'm going to use the concept of
graph data or of database views to talk
about how do I model the data. So, I'm
not bringing anybody into the graph
domain, I'm leaving everybody in their
relational um world where, you know,
most of the people are happier and I'm
saying, "Hey, what I need to create, I
need to create a type and the node
tables and the edge tables that I want
to bring in."
And does the data, right? So, types,
transformations or uh definition and
data. I have all the all those three in
the screen.
And this is you're going to see this
metaphor over and over in the
presentation.
I've added
the type to the graph. I added a node
table. I added the edge table. If
there's more than one edge table, you
know, do you see different blocks of
this?
Why is this important? What I'm showing
here is a sequence of things. Again, you
know, take you to to the database world,
I'm talking about serialization, I'm
talking about atomic uh addition to the
graph, I'm talking about a log, a ledger
for those that are uh inclined to to
think in uh in more modern technology.
It's a sequence of transactions it's to
a log. This is going to help me to
define a healthy graph and to be able to
grow it for any data in motion.
So, I've added one data set to my graph.
Another concept that I'm going to play
over and over is this uh
fluid metaphors on the right-hand side
of the of the numbered slides.
What I want to do is mix data together,
bring a couple of these different
colored uh fluids, put them together in
a graph, and have insights on that.
How do I do that?
I have a data catalog. All of you are
familiar with data catalogs. I take the
leaf data,
uh you know, the intermediate ones are
are unimportant. They're just uh
intermediate data sets that are, you
know, they don't make it into the graph
cuz they're not important enough to have
uh to be part of the model. And I want
to create um
a knowledge graph.
A graph without the ontology is just a
uh
knowledge base. If you have ontology and
reasoning, it's a knowledge uh graph.
So, this my terminology.
So, I take those data sets.
And just I like I told you before,
I keep on appending them
to a graph index. I haven't told you
anything about how I'm doing this index.
I'm just appending data sets one to the
other. The fact that they are disjoint
is helping me
uh in creating uh a healthy graph and
one that I can grow because if I bring
another one of those colorful tables, I
can just append it to this log. I can
create three more transactions, one for
the uh type, one for the uh node table,
one for the edge table, and I I grow my
graph.
Going back to the views, to the idea
that I'm just using views in the
relational database terminology, why is
this important?
All of you here have fought with
identity reconciliation and resolution.
What is identity? What is an identity
problem in graph? You have a node table
that has the same primary key twice.
And you don't know how to combine those
those rows because the properties that
are coming from those rows depend on the
order in which you read the table. If
you do updates, you don't know how to do
that. So,
the reason why this is important for the
view, you create a table with a uh
primary key that is not repeated, that
is unique, and therefore you don't have
the identity resolution problem. How do
you solve that?
Just figure figure it out in the view
level. In the relational part of the
problem.
You don't know how to do that, you're
going to have to have the problem of
identity resolution. It's easier, you
know, this this problems have been
resolved for many many years in the
relational space. You don't need to
reinvent the wheel. Just use the use the
the relational wheel that exists.
Um I'm also solving the problem of
composition. If the same column
has if the same column is coming from
two different tables, you're going to
have data collision happening because
the same values are going to be written
into the into your property graph from
two different sources. So, that's
another reason why you want the data to
be disjoint. How do you do that? You do
it at the view side of of the database
views at the table views
side, and if you if your data is
disjoint, then you don't have this
problem. So, all of a sudden everything
that's complex about the graph, I
externalize. I put it on the on the
definition side where I'm saying my data
is disjoint in the node table as a edge
table. I have primary keys for the node
tables, and my edge tables are creating
edges, multi-edges, you know, name name
your
your type of graph that you want to
build.
Another thing that's interesting for the
views, you all know in the relational
world you can update a view and it's
going to populate additional columns if
those changes are accretive. Everybody
knows how to do that. All your DBAs that
have been trained in the last 40 years
in SQL now how to do that. You don't
need to to teach them how to evolve
schema. They know it. Your graph is
going to grow automatically if you have
the methodology to create these joint
data sets with accretive schema changes
and with
additive data set. So,
I set up I set up how I built the first
graph.
Now I'm going to have to change it.
I need overlay graphs. So, you know, the
the metaphor the the visual metaphor
there is personalization. I need to
bring a little bit of my data and
overlay it on top of the of the big
graph. Think, you know,
your
um
personal uh your your personal portfolio
on top of financial data, right? So, the
financial data comes from a big graph,
you have your portfolio is overlayed
there. You you run you write a little
bit of a graph on top of uh the the big
graph. How do you do that?
Well,
I'm adding an an additional data set, a
small one,
to the big log.
How do we do that? All of us are coders.
Well, you do it in the same way that you
do it in code. You branch, you add
something in the branch, you read
through that branch, and when you're
done, you delete it. So, that's how you
do personalization with uh with
knowledge graphs at the systemic level.
You can do this for many overlay
patterns, right? So, experimentation is
one where, you know, somebody wants to
add a data set and see if they can add a
feature. You add a feature in a
uh private part of the schema, you run
your you add your data set in a in that
branch. You run your experiment. When
you're done, you release the data and
you decide whether you want to bring the
whole data set in or not.
Uh same thing for personalization, same
same thing for contextualization.
Contextualization is a
even more uh volatile uh form of uh
personalization. So, if I search now for
things in my Google Maps, it's going to
be contextualized to London because
that's my location. It's not. It's
personalized and contextual
contextualized.
And again,
same thing as a branch. You know, I
haven't invented anything for you. I
haven't invented database views. I
haven't invented branching. I'm using
systems and technologies that exist for
50 years.
I made a mistake when I submitted the
slides and uh I know all of you are
going to uh well, some of you are going
to look up ablation. This is the best
joke that I could come up with. That's
why I didn't fix it. Ablation is when
you take some data away. I forgot to put
the uh the data in the slides for this.
So, how do you do this in um uh in that
uh ledger uh model? You take some data
away. So, you delete some data from you
mask it. You you make it look like it's
uh is deleted. So, it's the same as
adding something for personalization
except you mask it. You mark it with a
tombstone.
Side-by-side graphs.
So, that's another uh model where, you
know, some people are doing Oh, is this
the model that will work better in my
application or is that the model? Is
the, you know, the red one or the blue
one or the green one the the one that's
going to be more useful? Which one is
going to
give me more profits? Which one is is uh
doing personalization better for for
your user?
Again,
just like in code. Oops.
Just like in code, you make two
branches, you make your application read
from the different two branches, and
you're doing AB comparison and AB
experimentation.
I haven't invented anything. I'm just
keeping you in the '70s. I hope this is
the most boring thing that you hear
about graph is that there's nothing new
under the sun.
Now,
let's go back to say, well, now I build
a graph, and I have a graph for my
entire data estate. If your data estate
is huge, and you have terabytes of
terabytes of of graph, it's going to get
expensive.
If you're having expensive data like
graph, which is over indexed, and it has
to be mostly in RAM, and you have to run
through it
a lot,
you need a high throughput to be able to
make it viable. That's why, you know,
people are asking me, "Hey, how is how
come that LinkedIn is paying
millions and millions of dollar to have
the graph in memory replicated 300
times?" The LinkedIn graph is 300
billion edges, 3 million QPS.
It's about 25 terabytes per replica.
There are about 150 replicas to do
global
serving.
How come it can afford that? Well, per
QPS, it's cheap.
Having it in this on disk, and paying
for the network cost is going to be
three times more expensive than having
it in RAM.
So, you just have to find the right
application for the right thing. So,
keeping all that LinkedIn graph in RAM
is actually the cheapest solution that
you can implement.
Any graph database that is creating a
copy of that and running it through
through network is going to be much more
expensive than that.
So, let's say that you have one of those
graphs, right? And that's the gold
colored
graph there. But, you also have some
slow data, some data that you only query
at three QPS and only Fridays, right?
You don't want to bring that data in RAM
because it's humongous. It's going to
add another
20 30 millions of dollars in cost to
keep it in RAM. So, for that one, you
make another graph, one that is stored
on disk. It has the same front end, the
same query language, the same way to
query it, but you put it in a different
place.
The third one is finance data. You don't
want to bring the finance data, you
know, the blue one is finance data. You
don't want to bring that one to
production because you're putting it in
the path of the user.
You're putting it You're putting your
company in the path of GDPR fines. So,
you want to be able to segment the data
such that you have the right domains,
and that's where the the the case for
silos is coming in.
You have your catalog,
but you want to have different domains
in the catalog that you're dealing with
differently for different reasons,
right? For cost reasons, for regulation
reasons.
And once you have these domains, you
know, you can create knowledge graphs
and ontologies on top of them. And once
you have the ontologies and they are
disjoint again, then you can figure out,
"Oh, I can query with this domain. I'm
going to query in that graph. With this
domain, I'm going to query in this
graph." You just have a router that is
intelligent enough to understand the
definition and the the types of each
graph and query them separately.
The same metaphor. How do I do this?
I do one log for graph one, one log for
graph two. And if I need to give access
to anybody to both of them, then you can
think of it as a log one plus log two,
and you give them access to the uh to
the combined one.
What kind of patterns do I have for data
domains, right? And And you're going to
recognize the business model of many of
the companies uh around here.
One of them is you have a core graph
that is uh you know, the the dark green
uh on top and you have variants that
people are are using on top of it. So,
where is this useful, right? So, you
have
a company that's building a graph for
pharmaceutical research, you know, it's
indexing all the the papers that existed
in the in the public domain. 5 minutes?
10?
Oh, I'm going to be done way sooner. Um
you have
the domain the the public domain and
then you
provide it to AstraZeneca and they bring
their data on top of it. You provide it
to Merck and they bring their data on
top of it. What is what is provided in
the core is public domain. What
everybody extends doesn't egress to to
the other company.
The second pattern is is the one that
all of you have
have seen in the big data domain.
You have a core gold data set that is
what your application uses in
production. You have the silver data set
that is the one that your
uh
uh your engineers, your developers are
experimenting with and and that they are
testing, they're measuring the quality,
they're improving. And you have the
bronze data set which is everything in
the world and
and everything that under the sun. Who
is using something like this?
Um
it's probably not a public knowledge.
Amazon catalog, the website works with a
model like this. Everything that you can
buy is in the gold data set. Everything
in silver is they're allowing listings
to be created, but they're not allowing
them to be sold to the public until they
understand that that data is high
quality and it can be used and they have
a business model on how they make money
and and so on and so forth. So, they run
simulations on that data. And then
everything else is kind of like the
open-ended
uh you know, eBay kind of model of
unstructured data.
And you have the the last pattern is a
tree organization where you have, you
know, finance and corp and prod and and
you have a a larger graph that combines
the three of them with, you know, some
observability and
so these are the the use cases for
multiple domains in a single data
catalog in a single estate.
And then last but not least, you have
streaming data.
And I told you my data sources I worked
really hard to make them disjoint. I
make them
I work really hard to make them
isolated. Now I can get different bits
of the and you have to look at the the
different colors, you know, I have
real-time data that arrives later. I can
process it as soon as I need. I append
it to the log. I keep a transaction log.
I make my data consistent with the with
those transactional guarantees and when
it's ready, I read it and my application
is going to work
if the application is designed well,
it's going to work
as expected. Where is it not going to
work, right? So you have digital
stability for algorithms. If you change
the graph while you're computing page
rank,
your algorithm is likely going to become
unstable. How do you deal with that?
Well, I told you, with a branch.
If you want to add fresh data to the
graph, you run the algorithm through a
branch that reads from a given point in
time and doesn't read past that time and
you keep updating the graph. And then if
you have a page rank that can do delta,
you take just the delta that you've
added and you compute the incremental
page rank on that and so on and so
forth.
So you have to understand the technology
that you're running such that you can
use the graph that you're creating. But,
you know, you want to add data to the
graph, you can add it. The LinkedIn
graph in production uses real-time data
in exactly this this fashion. It reads
data from Kafka feeds, it updates it. If
you don't want If you don't believe me,
connect with your neighbor, and then
figure out how long it takes for that
connection to show up in their app.
And that's the latency that the
uh the the LinkedIn uh graph database
has in production. It's about a second,
a second and a half. You can always
blame it on the uh on the mobile phone
and not on me.
In summary,
your data catalog allows you to define
domains, graph types, graph definitions
as views. Disjoint if you know, disjoint
is the goal such that you avoid the
problems of uh contention and uh
um
concurrency.
We accept change feeds if you can handle
it. If your application can handle the
change feed, you should have it. And
these are not systems that you have to
wait for. These are methodologies that
you can use today with whatever
technology you have.
That's the end of it.
>> [applause]
[applause]
>> Uh we've got time for questions.
And we have a mic in the back, too,
Aaron.
>> Wait. So, the
Do you have issues with scaling this
approach when you have a very, very
large log? So, if you're trying to do
everything in a log-based form and you
need to look back 10 years, 20 years,
you're then potentially playing forward
20 years worth of changes to the graph.
How does that hold up?
>> I mean, it it scales with the time if
you need to keep all of it in memory. If
you don't want to keep all of it in
memory, then you have to to read and
aggregate over time, or you need to read
the data for a certain interval of time.
So, that you don't always need uh the
entire data. So,
you have to design your algorithm in a
way that's uh that's workable, right?
So, it's a log. What I didn't talk about
is how do you compact this? How do you,
you know, keep the right window of it if
it grows? But, yeah, you know, that that
problem exists.
Uh
any data that you have in RAM and you
write a lot,
it becomes a problem in a log system.
So, you have to figure out how to
compact it or how to summarize it.
So, yeah, that's that's a pattern that
you have to deal with. Uh
you know, we we can talk about solutions
that we had, but compaction and
windowing is like in real-time systems
is uh is what we used.
>> Other questions?
>> Or a side key-value store, right? So,
you you you figure out which are
properties and then you write them and
you override them so that such that you
don't have to append them to the Yes,
Alister.
>> Hi Bogdan. Um
the views, are these views uh defined in
SQL um and updated in SQL, or is there
an attempt to actually provide a sort of
graph veneer like SQL PGQ?
>> All of the above, right? So, if if you
if if SQL is the language of choice, you
can define them in SQL, right?
Uh we I'm I'm not talking about any
system that I'm selling.
Right? I'm talking about methodologies
and systematic uses of uh of this. But,
yeah, defining these in in SQL or in KQL
if your database is um
uh a log-based system, you know, a time
series.
Any uh any language any database
language that has views provides you a
methodology to do it.
I'm agnostic on that, right?
When we're going to release a product,
we will create a, you know, a manual for
it and I suppose it's going to be a
sequel based.
>> Yeah, thanks.
>> Any questions?
Okay. Thank you very much for
>> Thank you.